sony already announced the PlayStation  VR bundle but now we know what's  included when you can pre-order it and  how much it'll cost you I'm Tony and  this game spot news update should make a  lot of you very happy the psv our bundle  includes the headset and cables  headphones demo disc playstation camera  to move controllers and playstation vr  world's on disk all of that will run you  five hundred dollars pre-orders open on  march 22nd at seven a.m. pacific 10 a.m.  eastern time the bundle will only be  available in limited quantities at  certain retailers so you better make  plans if you want the bundle on day one  and if you miss out don't sweat it there  will be a second wave of pre-orders this  summer the bundle is currently only  confirmed for north america we're still  waiting to hear about other markets in  any case PlayStation VR is due out in  October of this year in the meantime  keep an eye on gamespot for all the  latest in PlayStation